Hello and welcome to Quickstart your first project.
This course we will be using Unreal Engine version 5.6.
Now this is one of the first courses you should take if you're new to Unreal.
And by the end of this course we hope you will be able to
firstly create the right project set up for your goals,
navigate through the Epic Games Launcher and the Unreal Engine Editor,
have a good idea of how to import and manage assets inside your projects,
and move content to and from other tools.
Finally, we'd like to go over some of the main modes and features.
Now we're not expecting you to learn them from this video.
What we are hoping is that you'll have a good idea of what areas you need to learn in future,
specific to what you're hoping to achieve within the Engine.
Unreal Engine started out its life as solely a game engine.
It was built for the game Unreal Tournament, and this is how it's got its name.
However, over the years, not only has it been provided to other game studios
for creation of a lot of different games,
but it's also grown to be used in numerous other industries, as we'll go over here.
The main thing that is unique about a game engine is that it needs to produce
all of its graphics in real time.
Unlike other offline tools that can render frames over minutes or hours,
Unreal and other game engines need to do it instantaneously.
Historically, this would mean that we would have to sacrifice the quality of the output
so that it could be responsive and fun to play,
but as new methods of rendering have been invented and technology has improved,
we are able to achieve a quality of output which is very competitive versus other offline renderers.
Unreal these days is now being used in games from Indie to AAA,
ARC-Viz and simulations for training visualization and interactive tools,
VR and AR simulations,
and it's also being used in a couple of other new interesting fields such as virtual production.
This is used in filming where an LED wall is placed behind the actors when filming footage
and it can then be altered dependent on how the camera moves
and this can produce much higher quality in-camera footage
and save time in host production, cleanup and VFX.
Unreal is also used in a lot of human machine interfaces such as a lot of the cars that are brought out today
and used in things like the entertainment system.
The output from Unreal Engine is now so good that it is being integrated into a lot of traditional animation workflows,
allowing animators to see the end product much faster and quickly iterate on their product.
This is why the project setup matters a lot in Unreal Engine.
Different goals need different settings.
A project for an automotive HMI is not the same as one for a virtual production,
so starting with the right templates and options is going to save time and avoid headaches later.
Here at Epic Games, we have an entire ecosystem that is produced to support and complement Unreal Engine.
Now, there is a lot of tools coming from different stores, photogrammetry tools and things like metahumans.
First one is UEFN and this is Unreal Editor for Fortnite.
This allows you to build playable experiences inside Fortnite using many Unreal Engine features.
You can access a huge audience and earn based on player engagement.
The other option we have is Twinmotion.
It is a simplified, easier to learn, real-time tool,
primarily aimed at architectural and design visualisation.
This is great for speed and presentation, however you may hit some limits.
For that, you would need to move to the full Unreal Engine for advanced control.
So that brings us to the end of this introduction.
In the next video, we are going to download and install the Epic Game Launcher.
We are going to walk through the key launcher options and create our first project with the correct settings.
Thanks for watching. I will see you in the next video.